[inaudible]
I never thought of sharing culture or my own history.
Okay.
Comforts my heart knowing that I,
I'm allowed to do this without getting this trap whipped.
They're thrown in the closet anymore.
That's big for me.
The big for me,
cause this was sure,
took a lot of punishment.
It took a lot of punishment for a being a native person.
And this is just one of our ways of showing that
we're alive and well
give me a second.
Got Permission from my elders and my cheese to be allowed to use all of these,
all of these different meanings.
All the different designs.
I almost cried when they said use whatever you want.
I guess the reason why I was Craig Craig was because
okay,
you remembering
how much weight weight too
not allowed to draw a curve or talked to her English.
It's tough.
Did your mom on his street car parts?
You just,
she thought,
Huh?
Well
I was very lucky when grandparents were at home.
That's all I heard.
Go to a shit.
My grandparents to uh,
um,
when they had private house services.
Yeah.
Walk more and grinding is there.
And listen to your granny and them sing songs and
we'd have a house for elders,
for the elders all sit around and as they're walking in,
so grab a Bible or book that,
uh,
you know that their pupils reading or the hymns
and not order them the harder read.
But I guess it's just the thing to do is grab a Bible and sit down.
I don't know.
But when I was sitting there and my granny,
I sat there and watched check in it.
I yes,
what they do in there
and I watch that.
Yeah,
I seen him.
Every one of them were private Bible.
Not one of them would open up the book or just sit and start singing hymns and
[inaudible].
That's where I thought it core is here.
We do it in a park wall.
Oh
Wow.
When you become a prisoner,
it's not an easy life.
And that's the reason why my son Boon
decided to do this because that's the only way he could heal.
And when you start healing,
the changes of your life starts again.
That's when you become who you really are because we've carried so much pain.
So much hurts.
No granny's know.
GRANDPA's allowed to be close to us,
not allowed to speak our language.
Many things,
songs taken away from us,
our dances,
and we were not even allowed to embrace our families anymore.
Okay,
let me send that.
We'll all leave this world and when there's time for us to leave this world,
you have half the story.
You have something to town your children of what happened to us and our great
grandchildren,
that we were not just drunks.
We're not just alcoholics and drug addicts.
We picked up things that wasn't ours because we wanted to hide the pain,
and now today we're going to bless it so that we don't pull the pin out anymore.
Okay.
Ah Huh.
What can paint.